how old were you when you got Freaks and
Geeks I was young I was like maybe 19 or
20. just out of high school it is
amazing how that show is such a
kind of Rosetta Stone in a way for
so many great I mean not just a style of
Comedy but uh so many of the performers
have gone on to be kind of pillars
comedic pillars and and and have these
great careers yeah it's fascinating that
that happened it is uh I look back at
that period And there are other like
comedic groups who have had this but I
think that we really had the biggest
gift was we had the naivety of Youth
like we did not understand how hard any
of this stuff is and we were just
determined to make the thing great and
then like
Seth Franco and I would go to my house
on weekends and rehearse alone like
unprompted rehearse the scenes for the
next week and improv them and like try
every different version of them
I've never done that since like you
don't do that on a movie like we can't
get you out of your trailer no Harrison
Ford's not coming over to my house and I
can run these lines but I think that
there was something really special about
that about that period because look they
did like an international search for
Freaks and Geeks to cast that show like
none of us were even
were even that focused on like an acting
trajectory at that point we were all
just figuring figuring it out
then when we realized it was gonna be
hard this other thing happened where
when one person would do well they would
put other people in the other people's
movies and then slowly everyone's
becoming a little bit more successful
and everyone has their own movies this
is it was really special it's like you
had started a crime syndicate totally
totally that reminded me what you said
something I think is very true is I
Chuck up especially when I started my
late night show in 93 I was so young
that I didn't know
what we were up against I had a sense
yeah I had a very strong sense what we
mostly had was just youthful exuberant
we're gonna make this crazy show every
now we're gonna make another one and
then another one another no and then
another one and I think after like four
days we thought we did it and someone
explained to us no
you need to keep doing this for years if
you're going to make it if you're lucky
enough to make it but I but you did
don't you feel that way like your show
was Innovative and different and new and
felt so different than everything else
that was on TV but you know you don't
feel that way I mean this is what we're
like you don't feel any of that at the
time you don't all you feel is the
terror and the we've and you have little
moments of it and then my experience
with it has been you put all that on
hold you say someday if I if I can
survive this and get through it I'm
going to sit down and really appreciate
it but of course that doesn't happen you
put it on hold for so long you just
realize that you you spent a lot of time
coping uh and and I think that's how a
lot of people I mean that's basically
some of what you've described as well
which is you're going through it you're
trying to make something happen and then
uh suddenly you're told you're supposed
to feel a certain way and if you don't
feel that way you think something's
wrong with you did you have can I ask
you a couple questions yeah did you ever
have interviews I'm sure the answer is
yes but where it just like
uh it felt like the person was just not
good at this like of course yeah would
it how do you handle it this is my take
after many many many many years I think
and and things have changed now it used
to be that a late night show was how you
promoted a project yes now there are a
lot of people who are very good at
walking out in front of a room full
strangers in an audience Bright Lights
music's playing and sit down and be
charming and delightful for seven
minutes commercial break and then five
more minutes
um a lot of people are good at that and
then there are people who are uh it's in
their genetics they're just not meant to
do that they're wonderful at what they
do terrific they're amazing actors you
can get that camera really close
and they're they're fantastic but what
they're being what they're essentially
doing is saying we're going to bring in
this uh I don't know species that's
meant to live in the desert and we're
going to have it swim the English
Channel and they're just not meant to do
that and so there were many times where
people would come out and I could see I
mean these are iconic actors
who have nothing to fear but they would
walk out music playing audience and they
look like a lobster that was still alive
but it's shell
and I had real empathy for them they
were terrified so mostly I just felt
this is a flawed system it was always to
me the most stressful part of the whole
my whole job doing talk shows I think
that it is a much more vulnerable and
scary thing to say like I'm Jason Siegel
and I'm here to charm you that versus
being a character or like of course
watch this thing and and then also like
coming from Comedy I was mentored like
you have your three or four stories you
know how to tell it you have your punch
line like this is essentially like
stand up with another person kind of
like bouncing off of you which always
felt like so stressful to me I never
really felt at ease you know I came to
the conclusion at a certain point don't
try to make a circle a square meaning if
someone's coming on and they were
terrific actor I used to tell that
segment producers don't try to say come
on what's your funny what's your funny
story where you bought the bathtub and
it didn't fit and then you took a
come on come on
Charlemagne
It's gotta end where you take a you
know it just but I I I I just I I came
to this conclusion that if someone comes
out and the audience can tell that I
have real respect and reverence for them
yeah and we have a conversation
sometimes you could hear a pin drop and
they would leave and go like oh my God
that must have been terrible because
there were no laughs and I'm like
thinking no people just like hearing the
conversation to try and make everything
but a bing bad Bing but a Bing
is a mistake if it's not there yeah and
if you have someone who's talented in
that regard and can do that then fine
but trying to make things something
they're not is very uncomfortable to
watch
in any medium especially television and
that's what I left after all these years
is what I learned fairly early on is
don't try to you know don't have Anthony
Hopkins on and then try through segment
producing to have him tell 75
pre-prepared stories and jokes it's a
waste of Anthony Hopkins yes talk to him
and he'll be fascinating and he is
fascinating you want no weird thing it's
so weird that you say that I've made
friends with Anthony Hopkins really uh
like briefly yeah real prick by the way
yeah
randomly he would text me jokes really
yeah I would just get these jokes from
Anthony Hopkins like written out like
like from a joke book oh my God
yeah isn't that a weird detail of my
life it's so cool but it's just so funny
too that well you really blew it with
your segments okay man you could have
had something yeah he like really likes
like oh he kept asking me when should I
go to the dentist what time and I'm like
sure Anthony Hopkins you're a great
actor you should go
anytime you want because you're such a
great actor and you go like no Conan
what time should I go to the dentist it
really was like that kind of joke and he
just wanted me to say 2 30 and I
wouldn't do it he loves it oh and you
love that joke oh it's such a good joke
because with your tooth is hurting yeah
you understand yeah yeah yeah you're
it's a good time yeah um thanks Sono
you're always there for me